hey this is a really strange video
yesterday radical republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
visibly struggling to breathe on the
floor of the house
ranted about mask now you might be
saying david hold on are you saying mask
or masks i'm saying mask she was ranting
about mask i don't know why she was
saying mask singular
uh she was everything about this video
is very very strange and look at the
amount of disinformation she packs into
just a 90-second rant georgia seek
recognition
mr speaker
i'd like to address the house about how
children feel about
generator will masks
how children feel
how children feel about mask
what
the gentle lady is
without objection gentlelady is
recognized
thank you mr speaker i'd like to talk
about how children feel about mask
what now i know that a lot of the stuff
she does is her accent and people say
david you shouldn't really talk about
that like when she says mental as
opposed to mental that that's her accent
but does that include i want to talk
about how children feel about mask
that doesn't seem like an accent that
just seems bizarre you see while they're
watching television seeing super bowl
games where adults are filled
filling stadiums without masks and
why is she out of breath i mean just
none of it makes sense join themselves
while they see
concerts happen they see people go to
work they see adults going many places
all over this country without masks they
are forced to wear masks every single
day at school
they they are forced to wear masks all
of them and it's wrong actually it's
child abuse now i know that sounds like
strong words but it really is because
children are not at risk of covid19 now
that is a lie that is a lie the truth
about kids in covid is
that when the pandemic started
it did seem kids were less likely to
contract it remember that was the big
thing and that if they did they had mild
illness but as the pandemic has
progressed that has changed it's still
true that most kids will have only mild
symptoms but most people who get covet
have mild symptoms
we are seeing
more and more children's hospitals
across the country with surges in
pediatric coveted hospitalizations we
have seen some specific conditions
that are side effects of covid that seem
to almost only affect children so it's
very much this whole thing about kids
don't have to worry about covid is very
much untrue children are at the lowest
risk but do you know what's harmful to
children having their faces covered all
day long at school not being able to see
each other's faces not being able to see
their teachers faces not being able to
learn properly speech emotions and
having that connection seeing each
other's faces and learning from adults
seeing each other's faces this is sort
of like you didn't read the book and all
of a sudden the teacher calls on you to
tell us what was in yesterday's
20 pages that we were assigned like this
she seems very unprepared for this in
more ways than just the heavy breathing
now while democrats are going on with
the mask for thee and not for me kids
have had enough and they're going to be
future voters and they are sick and
tired of being forced to wear masks it
needs to end masking children is child
abuse now of course masking children is
not child abuse but anybody who's been
paying attention knows that the masking
is ending first of all
the kids don't really seem to mind the
mask that much i think i mind the masks
more more than the kids to be perfectly
frank but um the masking is ending the
masking is ending we've heard from new
jersey that they're going to end the
masking in schools
california is moving in that direction
new york is talking about it we're
clearly moving rightly or wrongly into
the endemic uh
phase
um of how we are accounting for this
virus and the masking is ending and
again why is she out of breath
why is she saying mask singular we may
never know you can see this clip if
you're just listening today we'll have
this clip up on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective i love vincero's watches
you've heard me talk about them before
they now offer sunglasses and a bunch of
other premium accessories for men and
women vincero is committed to creating
exceptionally crafted watches and
accessories and doing so ethically fair
pricing carbon neutrality vincero puts
their principles first which is
important to me i just picked up the
rogue from vincero in gunmetal and red i
love the intricate design on the watch
face and the multiple sub-dials the
durable black silicone strap looks great
with just about anything i'm wearing in
all of vincero's products whether it's
the watches the glasses men's or women's
you can just see and feel the quality so
if you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect valentine's day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
collective is giving my audience 15
off all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below